and welcome to Hannity this busy Friday
news tonight I'll coming up more of my
exclusive town hall with former
president Donald Trump including his
answer to this question
my question for you president Trump is
what would be your first priority when
you are re-elected in 2024.
also tonight the knives are out for RFK
Jr following his testimony yesterday's
hearing on censorship that the Democrats
tried to censor and don't forget on
Tuesday of next week we have our town
hall with RFK it's in New York City and
tickets are free and they're on
hannity.com all right but first we begin
tonight it is now very very clear that a
malignant cancer is within and
surrounding Joe Biden's presidency it is
growing it is growing daily it is
compounding to quote John Dean it now is
also clear that Joe Biden may be the
most corrupt president in American
history certainly in the modern era
investigations are heating up the walls
are absolutely closing in this is very
real House Republicans are now seeking
answers on the White House's
ever-changing story about Joe Biden's
involvement which he did not died
repeatedly during the campaign with
Hunter Biden's foreign business dealings
noting that there has been a quote clear
shift in the messaging in other words he
lied and demanding to know if this
indicates that President Biden knew a
lot more than what he was telling us but
Biden's bad week does not even begin to
start there on Wednesday we had
explosive testimony from two extremely
credible IRS whistleblowers who one of
which who previously testified and that
is that Biden's Department of Justice
slow walked the hunter Biden
investigation so the statute of
limitations would run out on the fact
that he didn't pay taxes and felony
charges would go away it also revealed
the bidens have taken in over 17 million
dollars from only some foreign sources
and Joe Biden well it is now clear knew
almost everything about Hunter Biden's
foreign business dealings and assisted
on many occasions on these deals and we
have a lot of evidence to that fact and
coming on the heels of this week's
bombshell hearing the long-awaited FBI
fd-1023 form was made public after
months of stonewalling by the FBI and
after reviewing the document it is now
clear why director Ray and the FBI
wanted to keep it hidden it also
implicates them for not doing their job
the formal Ledges that the bidens were
quote coercing barisma to pay them
millions of dollars to help fire the
prosecutor investigating the company and
the company that was paying his son
Hunter and apparently worked Joe Biden
even bragged about having the prosecutor
fired back in 2018. he bragged about it
all it's right there on tape table take
a look I had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from yats and yuk that
they would take action against the state
prosecutor and they didn't so they said
they had they were walking out to
Prescott and said no I said I'm not
going to or we're not going to give you
the billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting the billion dollars I said
you're not getting the billion I'm going
to be leaving here and I think it was
what six hours I looked I said I'm
leaving in six hours if the prosecutor
is not fired you're not getting the
money well son
got fired
son of a big I'm fired now among its
other shocking revelations was the
allegation that barisma knew that Hunter
Biden had no experience and they thought
he was dumb in fact the company's CEO
allegedly referred to Hunter as quote
dumber than my dog hunter himself even
acknowledged during a Good Morning
America interview that he had no
experience in oil gas coal energy or
Ukraine and probably wouldn't have even
been hired if it wasn't his last name
and his dad wasn't the vice president
take a look what were your
qualifications to be on the board of
arisma well I was vice chairman of the
board of Amtrak for five years I was the
chairman of the board of the U.N world
food program I was a lawyer for boys
Schiller flexner one of the most
prestigious law firms in the world you
didn't have any extensive knowledge
about natural gas or Ukraine itself
though uh no but I think that I had as
much knowledge as anybody else that was
on the board if not more in the list you
gave me the reasons why you're on that
board you did not list the fact that you
were the son of course yeah no what role
do you think that played I think that it
is impossible for me to be on any of the
boards that I just mentioned without
saying that I'm the son of the Vice
President of the United States if your
last name wasn't Biden do you think he
would have been asked to be on the board
of barisma I don't know I don't know
probably not I don't think that there's
a lot of things that would have happened
in my life that uh that if my last name
wasn't
Amtrak the UN I'm a lawyer probably not
now the source of the form the FBI
credible whistleblower the guy that
actually uh interviewed the Barista head
that form also says he believes the
payments made to the bidens were quote
illicit but the CEO bragged that he had
covered his trash attracts the form
comes after the WhatsApp message from
Hunter showing a very clear Shakedown
and mentioning his father sitting right
there next to him that's when he
revealed that a text to his daughter
about complaining about giving half of
his income to Pops and of course the
infamous message promising to hold 10
percent of their profit for the big guy
who we all know is Joe Biden and with
the revelation of all this evidence
Republican calls to impeach Joe Biden
our growing day by day I would say a
more important issue would be a special
counsel a more important issue would be
a criminal investigation enough is
enough it is time for a real special
counsel a real criminal investigation to
take place to investigate what is
rampant corruption this is no longer
about Hunter Biden Jim Biden Jill Biden
or any other member of the Biden family
although James Comer says nine of them
got paid this is about the president of
the United States Joe Biden we now have
what is a trove of credible evidence
that he used the power of his office as
the vice president of this country to
secure massive amounts of money for his
own family he is without a doubt in my
mind at least the most corrupt president
in U.S history least modern history all
evidence now points to Joe playing what
is a major role and Hunter Biden's Shady
business dealings but that has not
stopped him from his non-stop lying
about it over and over and over again as
he denied any knowledge during the
campaign take a look
president how many times have you ever
spoken to your son about his overseas
business dealings I've never spoken to
my son
I have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period And
what I will do is the same thing we did
in our Administration there will be an
absolute wall between personal and
private uh and and the government do you
stand by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes I stand by that statement
he lied we have the evidence and now the
form not only points to allegations of
the Biden's corruption but also what is
a massive major cover-up by Biden's doj
and FBI and according to the source that
the FBI trusted because they had
previously paid this Source hundreds of
thousands of dollars the FBI was well
aware that Jose Associates called him
the big guy and said the FBI began
receiving information on the Biden's
emberisma as early as 2017. so why are
we now uh learning just now all of this
why is it taken so long for them to
release these serious allegations to you
the public why was the FBI covering and
hiding for the bidens and Biden's doj
doing it as well these are highly
disturbing claims if true which would
pose what is a major threat to our
national security and that means we have
a compromised U.S president the public
has a right to know sadly this is far
from the first Biden family cover-up
according to a breaking report from the
New York Post the FBI told Twitter that
Hunter Biden's now Infamous laptop was
very real but the social media giant
well censored the story anyways because
a supervisor told all the other FBI
agents to be quiet after that we deserve
every answer to every serious allegation
against the first family it is now clear
that these groups are working hard to
protect Joe Biden the most corrupt
president in American history hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else